so I've managed to get my hands on a
brand new fifth generation Apple iPad
Mini the don't stress it's not inside
the box it's right here ready to unbox
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is David
homage and welcome back to the channel
today's video is a little bit special
for me because we've just reached the
1000 subscribers now I know for those of
you out there that's not a lot but for
me that's a huge step in the right
direction especially to continue making
these great YouTube videos for you guys
and also for myself so thank you for
joining me and let's get in to today's
unboxing of the fifth generation iPad
Mini
so just because we're talking about the
unboxing experience doesn't mean I'm
gonna do this unboxing the generic way
everybody else does it yes I'm gonna
show you guys exactly what's in the box
but we're not just going to talk about
what's in the box we're actually gonna
talk about this iPad Mini and we're
gonna talk about how it compares to the
rest of the iPad lineup excluding the
iPad pro because that's a whole
different beast inside the box today
we're gonna find your typical Apple
packaging you're gonna find the iPad
Mini wrapped in the plastic that is so
satisfying to peel and full disclosure I
could not wait to make this video so
this iPad Mini was definitely unpacked
before this video but everything was put
in the same place it came but isn't
actually any major openings you still
get to keep your headphone jack at the
top which is a fantastic win for most
people you have the volume rocker up and
down on the right hand side and the
power button on the top as you do with
most Apple devices to date at the bottom
of the iPad Mini you have your speakers
and also your lightning port the rest of
the device is very smooth with some
beveled edges I actually like the
beveled edges over the flat edges of the
iPad pro in a small device in a larger
device it doesn't make too much of a
difference personally I can actually
grab the whole iPad Mini with one hand
so the beveled edges make it a lot more
comfortable for you to hold even if it's
1 or 2 inside the box you're also going
to find
your standard lightning to USB a cable
it's approximately a meter long so it
isn't too long unfortunately
underneath the iPad Mini you're gonna
find the instruction manual and some
decals from Apple one thing that kind of
threw me off with this little packaging
here was a simple fact that when you
pulled out the cards the information
card the two Apple stickers and also the
iPad Mini dedicated instruction booklet
what you found was the simple fact that
Apple had actually gone ahead and tried
to kind of buff out this little
packaging and make it a lot thicker by
adding an internal layer of cardboard
that you can't pull out so when you're
actually opening it up and kind of think
there's no paper in there but
realistically there's nothing more
except those three pieces of paper and
also you're gonna find the 10 watt wall
adapter specific for the iPad Mini if
you also have an iPhone you're probably
going to notice that your generic
iPhones come out with a 5 watt charger
so it is a lot faster in charging when
you're comparing those two wall adapters
both iPad air and the iPad Mini have the
a12 Bionic chip in them which is
identical to the iPhone XR and the
iPhone XS unfortunately one thing we
haven't seen on the new iPad Mini and
the iPad air that we have seen on the
iPad pro is the introduction of the USBC
connector it would have been really nice
to see the USBC added into this but I
guess you can't have everything along
the way
the improvements from the fourth the
fifth gen are phenomenal so it is a very
thankfull upgrade if you're comparing
the Apple Mini 4 and the Apple mini 5
there is about a three times performance
spec bump between the chipsets in these
two devices the speakers on this device
are actually quite good I'm gonna give
you guys a quick test here to show you
what the speakers are like through the
generic sound of this Canon DSLR there
isn't any external mic plugged into the
Canon during the audio test so it won't
be the best audio but here's a little
snippet for you guys if you're
interested in the audio quality
what's going on guys my name is David
Ulrich welcome back to the channel today
we're gonna be talking about the old
Microsoft laptop - and also the brand
new Microsoft Surface from laptop 3 that
was released just a couple days ago and
if it is a viable option to upgrade from
your old laptop I say oh it's
potentially about a year if not a little
bit more older the fifth generation iPad
Mini is also compatible with the first
generation Apple pencil it isn't
unfortunately compatible with the second
generation pencil which would be really
good at the moment only the brand new
iPad pro is compatible with the second
generation pencil which is a bit of a
letdown it would have been really nice
to see the brand new iPad Mini and also
the brand new iPad air be compatible
with the Apple pencil 2nd generation but
that's ok it's not too much of a letdown
the first generation pencil is still
pretty good I'll probably go ahead and
make a video on the comparison a little
bit down the track so stay tuned if
that's something that interests you if
you're out there comparing the iPad the
iPad air and the iPad Mini which the
naming of those it's actually quite
confusing because when we're talking
about the MacBook Pro and the MacBook
Air most of us out there know that the
MacBook Air isn't as powerful as an
Apple pro so logically you'd be thinking
that new iPad air wouldn't be as
powerful as a new iPad but in actual
fact the iPad Mini and the iPad air of
both more powerful than the original
iPad at the moment guys I'm getting
about 8 hours of battery life out of
this device they are saying 10 hours
along with the iPad Mini the iPad air
and also the iPad all getting the same
so 8 hours out of a 10 hour spec time is
actually really good and that's all I
have for the unboxing today for you guys
I'll be sure to do a review of the iPad
Mini a little bit down the track when I
get to use it a little bit more and give
you my full impressions but for today
thank you so much for watching if you
haven't already made sure you smash that
subscribe button
20:19 style we've just surpassed that
one
mark so I think the next goal for me is
5k but we'll see how we go again thank
you so much and I'll see you next Monday